so my name is Charles Arthur I'm a
technology journalist I've been covering
science technology and business further
something like 30 years most recently I
was 10 loans ietters at The Guardian
before that I was technology editor the
independent I was also for a period of
Science and Technology editor before
that I was at New Scientist before that
I was a business magazine before that I
was a computer weekly tech science and
they're a little bit of health I mean I
the science thing crossed over into
health when I did a lot about BSE and
variant CJD which was an interesting
time I think that we're in a period of
what I call tech stasis where we aren't
seeing any great changes in the
technology environment around us if you
think back to say 2007 2010 that sort of
period there was enormous change going
on in the world Apple introduced its
iPhone Google introduced Android Samsung
and other big companies jumped onto the
Android bandwagon Microsoft introduced
Windows Phone to make up for Windows
Mobile which was falling behind them
blackberry was fighting to stay as they
in existence palm was trying to come up
with smart phones there was gigantic
change happening there were enormous
sort of growth areas in all these spaces
now speaking in 2018 we've got a point
where Apple has 15% of the smartphone
market and Android has 85% of it and
there's no sign of that changing except
by one or two percentage points either
way in for the foreseeable we'd we know
where it is we know what's happening
Moore's Law the dictum that processor
power would increase by a factor of two
every 18 months has effectively stopped
because they can't make processors any
smaller so they add more cores but as
you have more cause you don't actually
get that sort of increase in power so
Mallis law has stopped there's no more
fighting in the smartphone space when
you think of what's the most dramatic
new technology you've seen it's stuff
like smart speakers where you know it
sits in your kitchen and you set a timer
for it or
you asked her to play a piece of music
or you also get to City question or
something and that's that's about it but
you know you could do the same with your
phone and there's there's no sort of big
changes and the thing I think that it's
only gets journalist interests but I
think it also gets people more generally
interested is when there's big flux when
there's a lot of change happening and
I'm just not seeing that at the moment
and it's a bit hard to say why not I
think it's partly because smartphones do
so much that they've really captured our
ability to do so many things in this
little black screen that means that you
don't need anything else in your life I
mean Google tried with Google glass
arguably it was too early but also
arguably they just didn't do enough you
need glasses that would do everything
magic leap has got a billion dollars in
funding and they've come up with
augmented reality glasses but people
have tried them and they don't seem that
impressed by them Microsoft is trying
the same with folio lens I've tried
hololens and it's not going to take the
world over virtual reality doesn't see
me going anywhere that as a market is
you know if anything's shrinking so the
question is when's the next big change
going to come where is it going to come
from some people might say blockchain
but I think not really I think that
that's just to energy-intensive too full
of scams there's just not enough
happening there it's got to be in second
order effects so rather as uber was an
application which was built on top of
the smartphone I think the next things
that that are going to change how we
think of it technology had to be things
that are built on top of the existing
platforms but for the moment for the
next few years I think we're gonna have
to just get used to what we have and
it's I don't know it just feels like
stasis it it's the longest period I can
remember when very little changed so
they're just gonna be a thing you don't
need to replace it just does what it
does do you think I think that's already
the case I mean you know people have
have a PC a desktop PC a laptop
now hang on to that for years mine is 6
years old and I still don't see any need
to change it people were hanging onto
tablets for longer and longer so that
market
you know really flattened out with
smartphones you know people are just not
as eager as they were to grab the the
latest and greatest and that's affected
Samsung you know it's to some extent as
affecting Apple so yeah I think people
just get satisfied with what they have
and then they're looking for something
new but rather is for the desktop you
could tell that the desktop was over
when people stopped developing apps for
it you know it stopped being for the
desktop first and that happened in 2010
though that was when the last big apps
that happened first on the desktop what
happened and that was Dropbox and
Spotify they both happened in 2010 and
the next big apps after that was
Instagram that was only on the mobile
phone it was years before you could get
anything to do with Instagram on the
desktop and then after that you have
things like care what's up and so on and
it all moved to mobile but now there's
no other platform it's yeah mobile is
where everything happens and I don't
know it just just feels like we're we're
having to sort of live with it but but
it's almost as if that this you know the
mine is sort of worked out that there's
there's nothing new it's always very
dangerous obviously to say that to say
oh well that's all it's all been
invented I think there was some of them
back in 1996 or something I said well
that's it you know that's it for a while
we've invented everything but I just
feel that with everything in the stasis
that it is that it's very difficult for
something to break through dramatically
for a small company to come up with
something here and the way that Google
did back in 1996 when they were brand
new and they were able to overturn the
whole search engine world one doesn't
get the feeling that there's the same
weakness that because the big companies
are so big you know the apples and the
googles and the Microsoft's of this
world and the Facebook's and the
Twitter's and the watch you know I think
they're all so big that if a small
company starts to come up then they can
swap what they're doing and they can get
ahead of them
and I should caveat this by saying I'm
going we're talking in general terms
each operating system with us Windows
Linux Mac or iOS BSD insert your
favorite operating system here that you
probably